[Music]
what is going to go down at the National
in Chicago this year I'm literally
spending four days at the National
Convention as a dealer I'm coming
guns ablaze all of America we're I'm out
of control for four days I called this
man's wife and convinced her to let him
come to this conference
he wasn't covered he's like have a good
time everyone I'm devastated I'm like
giving your wife's number I'm gonna do
crazy [ __ ] I'm not like Vera they've
been
I'm gonna like try to break the place
you got your prospective
[Music]
been here since Tuesday night got in
super late three-hour delay got in
Wednesday holiday been here with my best
friend Brandon Warneke man who runs a
wine library sign up for wine text calm
this is [ __ ] 1992 for us sure is 1992
action fans bunch of myself little new
hazard out Tyler holding it out d rock
you've even showed some business skills
which is really amazing to me and I'm
proud of you it is now what is it
Saturday late afternoon it's a full day
tomorrow devastated rammons leaving
still gonna try to talk about a bit just
having a best [ __ ] time best [ __ ]
people trying to let them make cash and
I'm considering becoming a full-time
sports car dealer and shutting down
vaynermedia first of all I'm just
unbelievably humbled to be here I'm an
immigrant that was born in the Soviet
Union I grew up in New Jersey very
lemonade stands very much sports cards
you know for a lot of us of a certain
age here 87 tops was like a rite of
passage it was like the crescendo moment
it was like it just you know the
sixth-grade baseball card club in Edison
New Jersey changed the course of my life
I got very into this world and basically
I'm one of the great all-time terrible
students because I spent ninety nine
percent of my time between the ages of
10 and 16 reading Beckett and tough
stuff and trying to buy cards I grew up
from such humble beginnings and that I
was never able to afford to come to this
convention as a kid and would always
read about it and dream about it so this
is a substantially surreal moment for me
to me happiness is about doing what you
want to be doing too many people focus
on the money the things that come along
with it I think you have to focus on the
process this is the [ __ ] best
I missed shows so much I've ran the
impregnate all do those at thirty
cheater stays at eighty these this
during this little thing is that twenty
tomorrow I'm raising the prices by ten
bucks each I'm being dead [ __ ] serious
very simply we have to make happiness
the North Star
we have to because the framework of all
of us over the last hundred years is
success and even worse things my great
hope is that happiness becomes a Nord
start equal to financial success because
it's so much better that's awesome but a
real pleasure man thanks thank you so
much for buying that real nice for your
help and your here or how long the whole
week come back for other times all right
yeah here bro take a pack and if you
pull up if you pull assigned auto of
mine then then you get it then you get a
twenty-five thousand dollar business
consultation say well one of the big
things that I'm passionate about is are
you doing something you enjoy to do like
happiness and fulfillment has to become
a much bigger part of the conversation
than financial upside I'm always very
hurt when people think that I'm pushing
hustle and too much work and make it for
the money
you know my behavior doesn't map to that
I would have been a venture capitalist
then like I'm talking about actually
liking what you do come on you're out of
control
thank you so much really
stop by for - Owens will hang one more
time real pleasure you know these are my
very first vintage cars ever bought
let's go
smart move now you get the right story
boss I'm curious I'm looking into the
national her a bit last year I did what
was really the tipping point awareness
wise or just seeing the Hobby or your
life this is this is the differentiator
this is what brought me back for me it's
the nature of flipping you know the
macro trend of 14 15 16 year-olds buying
and selling sneakers is something that
I've watched for seven or eight years
when I really analyze that market the
kids are getting far more sophisticated
this is not what I saw from kids seven
eight years ago where they do stay in
line for four hours flip a supreme and
be pumped to make their 300 bucks this
is running hard core tech to map things
on the web this is having 44 kids in our
high school stay in lines for them you
know the 15 16 year olds that I interact
with on the Instagram on DM they remind
me of me who at 13 and 14 I already knew
what the outcome was going to be with my
professional career which I thought I
was going to be successful and I can
sense my own when I talked to them I
some of these 13 14 year-olds feel to me
like you know I'm trying to figure out
how to invest in humans and take 20% of
the upside of a 14 year old because I
could see it and what I started noticing
was frustration around supply they
weren't able to get enough when they
were right and then I started sensing
cards momentum watching the market and
basically there it was a series of a
couple conversations where I just
noticed and I intuitively have decided
for myself that sports cards much like
nerd culture and comic-con and Marvel
movies much like sneakers that there's a
bubbling of it being cooler and more
scalable that it has this has been an
inside hobby it's a lot of people I'm
seeing right here that I know had been
to the last 22 Nationals 15 Nationals
and over the last three or four based on
the homework I'd done the runes getting
younger and compared to a decade ago and
that's good we need to change the
conversation period about the
aspirations not to be a millionaire it's
to be happy if I can replace the word
millionaire with happy and I'm crazy I
think I can pull it off literally I'm
doing what I did when I was 16 years old
with this guy
my best friend Brandon Weir and my were
literally doing a show
young fun like imminent and in and
uncomfortable like can I muster up the
courage to quit everything I'm doing and
only be a baseball card dealer like that
much fun happiness it's the a it really
is and I preach it and like I'll be
honest with you I'm scared that I may do
something weird like that at some point
just garage sale and do baseball card
shows happiness happiness is progression
happiness is the [ __ ] progression
life's about alternatives like either
you're happy and optimistic and moving
forward for you're unhappy pessimistic
and looking backwards you want to go
home and go to sleep and duality
you want to complain like you're more
than welcome to to me it's a very simple
game this is binary what's the
alternative
there will be a garyvee carton here
which for anybody you can imagine if you
grow up think about this if you grew up
loving and flipping sneakers and one day
you had your own signature sneaker
that's what these cards are for me this
has literally been the best week of my
life
really yeah man this is just like I'm
like literally sad that it's Saturday
night like I don't do five days of
anything
d-roc will tell you I fly to give a
speech in Hawaii and fly back I'm there
for four minutes like I never stay
anywhere ever I wish I could live here
for the next year this is as good as it
gets [ __ ] Wednesday who said 100
faces a cab yeah what a baseball great
show yeah lot going on I love you
you